well my dear compatriots at the moment  that I speak to you terrorist attacks of  an unprecedented level are happening in  the Paris Area there are dozens dead  there are many injured it's a horror we  have at my command mobilised all  possible forces so that we can  neutralize the terrorist threat and  secure all the areas that could be  affected I've also asked for military  reinforcements in the paris area to be  sure that another attack cannot take  place i have also called a cabinet  meeting which will take place in a  couple of minutes two decisions will be  made a state of emergency will be  declared which means that certain areas  will be closed being in those areas will  not be allowed the state of emergency  will be declared throughout the district  the second decision I have made is to  close the borders who must be sure that  nobody can enter to commit whatever acts  they may commit